welcome to this video playing gloaty for
gloaty for from Argentina let's see
tinks onion and while he's playing the
tory attack ok let's see with III over
c3 c3 and III this is the most solid
form of this opening not easy at all to
get any interesting players black let's
see now one idea is if I've but it might
weaken my own position so especially
weakling the lights quarry as if i play
e5 ok but let's try to to unbalance the
position a bit and then get some
pressure against you for you probably
will take no on see if no he doesn't
yeah that's so quite surprising ok so
I'll take the chance to take on deform
the some most likely will be slide
weakness I'm not really sure what Queen
B 1 is about you mean you will never
ever sacrifice on g6 don't see that
happening
yeah now we get a position if he
captures with the pond where his knight
on f3 is just defending the d4 pawn
which one is checking so he's avoiding
that may be a good idea still I don't
mind that this looks like a very decent
positioned it sounds just the tech the
default pond and see how he how he
covers it Knight f3 am I can play Bishop
hmm can i play Bishop g4 yeah I guess so
Bishop g4 intending to take it and take
before you know this looks like a normal
IDM I was briefly thinking that Bishop
takes Bishop g6 but it's not it's not
really really on okay someone killed
should maybe gain gain this temple on
the on the bishop on e to
that's a strange move all the way back
to the one probably but b2 is hanging
and now I'm have 94 even g5 and 95 yeah
well he's giving me all these moves with
the temple so now i can take be too well
to probably should take it i have lights
is really gave me so many free moves
that now it looks like an I'm
substantially better let's see that's
not ever died c3 also the taking on b2
was mostly to get the square not to get
the pawn now then i can i can just take
a to no real reason not taking it yeah
there's still 93 something better okay
this is enough checking the Queen the
rook everything quite resigned yeah the
hope all his pieces are hey sir so it
took bit too much yeah well this is it
was a serious of far too passive news I
think on e5 he probably should just take
hoping to exploit the light square
something like this and now I'm I don't
know a normal move Queen eat or
something so maybe my light squares are
slightly weak it's not a big deal we can
play gt5 and moves like that but this is
maybe what you should do the Queen Queen
be one already gives me gives me good
play because I just have a weakness to
attack on d4 and it's already tricky now
not be three days
I turn sure it's already already a
problem right here so it's tricky what I
was mentioning this is this is an idea
but I thought that this should be good
he needs to give this check which looks
weird just needs to save the piece this
is what I saw and now i can take default
with any piece deform with the queen
with the bishop i don't know but it
looks like like ass better I'm basically
porn up the Jeep on I'd have the better
my nappy so this isn't an issue but now
I got to get so many so many moves for
free yup like as winnings minus three
already by the comp yeah this just just
wins the house can go here the question
is where to take the easiest is Bishop
e6 even okay just just too much alright
thanks for watching